most of this generation quits the second
they get talked to you did this wrong
you did this wrong it's so easy to be
great nowadays most people are weak this
is a softened generation so if you have
any mental toughness any ability if you
have any fraction of self-discipline the
ability to not want to do it but still
do it people have a hard thing to
understand I hate to run and what makes
me so crazy people go well why do you
run if you hate it what are you talking
about I don't want to take showers and
eat either I hate that too that's a life
man it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody I hated
going to school so guess what I was Dumb
and one plus one is two but if you
can get through to doing things that you
hate to do on the other side is
greatness that's what people understand
by me running I am callous in my mind
I'm not training for a race I'm training
for life I'm training for the time when
I get that two o'clock in the morning
call that my mom is dead or something
happens tragic in life I don't fall
apart hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because when I started
my first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn what you need
to start doing for a successful life
enjoy
I'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so I can handle
what life is gonna throw at me because
the life I've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you
and if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody you said I can be me
the second you said I can cuss and be me
and cussing people I said man you cuss
all the time why well I hate to say it
the best way for me to get how I feel
across
I can't seriously you know what I went
through whole weekend man it was it was
really hard
no that
takes your damn Soul rips it inside out
and then they say now we're going to
start
it it allows me to express right where I
was at at a point of my life if I don't
give you all of me why the hell am I
here
why how will you learn from me people
take so much offense to me you will
never learn from people if we always tap
dance around the truth oh God I love
that we tap dance around the truth by
finding the right word so I don't hurt
you because you have thin skin no
tighten up people it's okay trust me
it's okay you might be called one
day
it's okay
you might be calling some Jewish word or
some or gay word it's okay let them call
you that what are you going to do now
they don't own your life how are you
going to control that now how are you
going to flip it upside down and say
Roger that now I'm gonna harness
and you'll read about me years from now
rule number two is flip your money with
Grant Cardone so if someone's got
between a thousand and ten thousand and
they're trying to multiply it to a
hundred thousand
what would be the steps they would take
how long do you think it would take them
to go from a thousand or ten thousand to
multiply it and would you say put that
all in your own personal investment uh
when you put it invest in the business
that you're in would you invest it in
other things that cash flow appreciate
and provide tax shelters what would you
do if you got a thousand dollars I would
like just keep you know keep investing
in yourself until you got another
thousand okay and and then invest in
yourself you know now you got 2 000
investing you go go you should start
making money faster at some point you
should start like every time you make an
investment in yourself if I put fuel in
my car it's supposed to take me further
right right so if I invest in myself
then and look you know there's things I
bought that I didn't get a return on
right away
but I didn't quit investing in a course
or a workshop or training or education
because it didn't work for your health
or I spent 17 years going to school none
of it was any good for me but it did
teach me it did teach me how to go to
school
right you know how to study how to study
how to go there how to how to complete a
course like I completed college I'm not
proud of that by the way you're not
proud of you completing that no no
because it was still it was ridiculous I
should have dropped out like I knew it
was a bad thing
uh major in accounting it's a good
degree it's not like just some you know
Business Degree right oh you should have
dropped out of it 100 because I I mean I
would still I would still I would well
I'd have a five-year jump on my career
but the problem is I was on drugs so so
you know physics actual drugs I wouldn't
have been on drugs I would have quit
college
because I would have had enough
confidence in myself when you're on
drugs you can't have confidence
because you know you know you're drugged
right so everything is second guess
because like my self-esteem was like
like through through the basement
and so I'm like I need to quit college
but everybody around me oh no you got to
finish college you got to finish college
I'm like what do I know I'm a drug
addict and if I drop out I don't have a
degree then I gotta hire me and yeah I
didn't even worry about any of that
because you know I didn't worry about
that I just didn't have the confidence
to follow my intuition you can't when
you're on drugs when you're not yourself
and so what do you do with a thousand
bucks right right um
you know I think you just got to keep
investing in you until like oh now I'm
making three thousand dollars okay boom
reinvest all that again but what we do
is we start taking it off the table
right and we say when we don't invest it
so I think people just need to get on
that that cycle of like okay I'm gonna
keep repeating this activity I'm going
to reinvest the money in myself go to
the workshop or whatever Monday I got to
be hustling again until okay now I got
four thousand dollars okay now I got
five thousand now the income's starting
to pick up income has to pick up in the
income should be an indication that
whatever you're learning is helping you
that's interesting until one day you're
like okay I have more money here than I
can actually invest in myself I can't
like there's nothing I can go to to get
rid of this money you need to get rid of
that money though all my free time is
going to my workshops I don't have more
free time to invest in me yeah I'm
developing skills I'm working I'm
earning more yeah now what's the next
step yeah and now now it would be okay I
got to spend money on marketing I
wouldn't go make I wouldn't go look for
an investment right now I'm gonna spend
money on marketing now now now I'm gonna
spend money on marketing to give me more
leads and I would you know big mistake I
made in my career was not spending more
money on marketing because you turned
what 50 when you really started
investing I was 50 I was 51 when we
started playing the social media game
and and I was probably 56 55 or 56 when
we started spending money on marketing
wow yeah 51 when you started doing
social media yeah yeah
and I should have been spending money I
should have been spending money when I
was 25 years old when I was selling cars
I should have spent money I've been
spending money on ads but I was scared
man
so so what made you not scared 25 years
later 26 years later at 51 I started
studying hey what what are all these
successful people have in common
you know whether it was the mattress
dealer the car dealer the furniture
dealer or Elon Musk they spend money man
you know they spend money they spend a
lot of money
and they don't worry about money the way
I was worried about it they use money
you know they used it they didn't save
it they didn't hoard money
and the greatest companies on this
planet today the ones that have just
like some of these companies have lost
money for 25 years look at Amazon yeah
reinvest 1.7 million employees when I
started I remember I looked at Ernest
young I said I had a buddy that worked
at her Channel I said how many employees
you got he's like 240 000. wow and I'm
worried about 10 people what am I
thinking
so so when I quit studying individuals
and started studying people everything
shifted for me
when I quit trying to be the you know
when I quit worrying about what Bob was
doing or Pete or whoever and started
saying hey man what is this big company
doing because that also relieved me of
being competitive with this guy Pete and
started saying okay I'm gonna go do what
Coca-Cola does that's what I'm about to
play right really yeah how were you when
I was playing I was uh 50 maybe 55 the
first one I bought it because because I
studied what Coca-Cola was doing
they bought planes I said why are they
buying planes oh then I learned how they
write them off and then I learned how
they trade them every three years that's
crazy so notice every three years I'm
trading a blank I'm getting rid of it
replacing it with another one but what
are they using it for they don't use it
for pleasure
they're not using it for Instagram
photos they're using it to go and set up
headquarters in other countries wow
you know so so that's when I wrote uh if
you're not first or last because when I
started studying these companies I'm
like Coca-Cola's everywhere you can't go
anyplace and not see Coca-Cola
and and I was
I was like this big I was always
thinking about what can I keep and they
were thinking about how many shells can
we get on
how many eyeballs can we see
so that's when that's when it all
clicked for me you know and then that
goes back to that thing about the
financial misinformation right it's like
who am I studying and and that's that's
when we started you know opening up the
funds for for I was at uh went to New
York City to go walk in Goldman Sachs
and JP Morgan's offices I wanted to walk
in and see what it was like
these are 100
multi-hundred billion dollar companies
crazy you know and I walked in I was
like oh my God man I just it just all
hit me in a second
I've been doing everything wrong what
were they doing different they owned the
building they were renting the building
they owned the building well they don't
care if they rent they could rent it but
they own the elevators were bigger than
the studio all right one elevator
and 60 people got in that elevator and
went to the went to the 120th floor and
then there was six six of these
elevators
people going up and down everybody told
me don't take people's money do not let
investors vets invest with you keep the
whole deal for yourself the second I
walked into Goldman Sachs because all
they're doing is getting investor money
that's all they do
okay and the difference is what I do is
I I could go to Goldman I was there they
would give me money and I'm like I'm not
going to get money from them
I'm gonna do what they do for my
individuals exactly from my friends from
people that follow me from people that
support me okay Goldman Sachs will give
money to anybody right
okay they don't know how to go to these
people
they're not on Instagram or Facebook or
LinkedIn or Tick Tock so I'm going to
create a font
where I can tell my audience
hey Lewis you can invest with me I'm
going to kick Goldman out of the deal or
JP or whoever there's a bunch of these
these guys you know it's not that
they're doing a bad thing or anything
I'm not saying they're they're they're
the devil but they're close Okay because
they they're they're not going to call
you and say how you doing man you know
without saying hey you got any money to
invest it's just not you know that's not
what they do their job is to make money
period so anyway when I saw that I'm
like okay these people are these are the
richest institutions on the planet they
fund everything that happens
um the company BlackRock blackrock's
going to be BlackRock and Vanguard these
are multi you know probably going to be
worth 20 trillion dollars each in the
next handful of years the loan they they
say they'll own 99 of all the assets on
planet Earth not just in America how are
they able to do that
because because they scale right because
they think they think big so they they
you know they're funding everything
everything that happens on this planet
from media to pharmaceutical is going to
be funded by those two companies so
it just when you're when you're studying
your Rich uncle or the neighbor down the
street the the think is only so big and
then when I started studying these other
companies I was like okay this is who if
you want to create that kind of
Legacy wealth and really help a lot of
people because they're they are in a
position to help or hurt a lot of people
that's the scale you got to think at
rule number three is create something of
value with Tom bilyu my question to you
is if I was starting from scratch as in
I had zero dollars in your opinion what
will it take for me to get rich in three
years whoa okay getting rich in three
years that's that is a very aggressive
timeline
the only way that you're going to get
rich in three years and we should
probably Define that I'll say seven
figures or higher seem like a reasonable
Baseline
okay so the only way that you're going
to get that kind of wealth is and I'm
assuming that you're not able to invest
something go buy something or something
like that so we're literally starting at
scratch so you're going to have to
create a company create something that
generates a lot of value
typically that's going to be a company
so you're going to create a company that
meets a very well-known need that has
not yet been serviced by a product that
is relatively easy to get across the
finish line and into the marketplace it
needs to be something that is going to
resonate with social media and it needs
to be something that doesn't cost a lot
of money to get started so either you're
gonna layer on way better marketing so
if somebody has a solution to a
well-known problem but they don't know
how to Market it you can go and partner
and say hey look I understand marketing
I'm going to be able to get this out
there or if you have an information
product that can be associated with a
known problem that you uniquely can
solve I happen to know a little bit
about your background so if there is an
element to working in the music industry
to becoming a professional singer
improving your voice or something like
that that you really have a beat on that
you know a lot of people are interested
in that you could turn into a course for
instance that people would really
resonate with
that could be a great one the reason
that I keep coming back to information
products is you're looking for something
that doesn't cost money up front if
you're going to like take Quest
Nutrition for instance when we were
building that there was still a
substantive amount of investment that we
had to make even just buying uh a bunch
of protein powder was expensive buying
the liquid fiber you have to buy them at
55 gallon drums so it's like there were
still thousands of dollars that we had
to put in in the beginning and so to
find something that really takes little
to no money down you're either going to
be doing an information product or
you're going to be doing something that
you can make yourself that doesn't have
expensive uh constituent parts or you're
going to be finding something that's
already made that the person doesn't
understand marketing so it's really
about what is the bit of value that
you're going to be able to bring to that
that's unique that somebody else can
easily replicate that the world is going
to know instantly that they need and you
just have to make them aware of it
because three years is fast
and so quest for instance depending on
what you mean by Rich so for instance
three years into Quest we had a billion
dollar brand but I was I didn't have a
billion dollars that I could put in my
pocket so I was still driving I think by
then I had finally upgraded my car but
for a first couple years of that I was
still in a beater car even though I was
worth a lot of money and so if you need
the money to be in your pocket that's
probably going to take a fair amount of
time longer and if I can take a minute
to get everybody watching to understand
the difference between net worth and
income that would be really valuable so
if you don't mind generating a million
dollars plus a net worth now we're back
to you just have to build something that
other people say that they want
to have the actual money in your bank
account you have to build worth in
something that people say that they want
and then you have to sell that thing so
it's very rare that you're going to get
rich off of the operations of your
business you get rich by building a
company where somebody's looking at that
God this is going to get complicated
fast so ask follow-up questions so
you're either going to build something
that's going to IPO okay initial public
offering and what you're saying is hey I
built this really cool thing it makes a
lot of money or people think it's going
to make a lot of money and by going to
the SEC they'll actually let me
fractionate my company break it into a
bunch of pieces known as shares and then
I'm going to sell some of those shares
on the open market the public markets
and then people can buy those shares and
so that's a way that you're going to be
able to put that money in your pocket
but you're you're literally selling a
piece of the company that you own
otherwise you can sell a minority
controlling or total interest in the
company to private Equity Venture firms
something like that but usually when
people do that they're not doing it for
founder liquidity they're doing it
because they expect you to invest the
money back into growing the company
which is why IPOs get people really
excited because some of the shares you
will sell as part of the company
treasury which generates operating
Capital some of the shares will be yours
personally that you get for being a
founder and so you can use that as a
liquidity event so now you actually have
that money in your pocket
but most people in three years it's
gonna be tough you could get to an IPO
stage but that's going to be a really
rare moment that again follows the
equation of you're solving a problem
that people already know exists in a
very Dynamic way that people are
basically falling over themselves to
give you money for and you've actually
created a a company that can be sold
which is we could do a two-hour class
just on what that means so it's
interesting when you ask that question I
really want to give you a hot sexy take
and just be like oh go do this but the
reality is to to have a seven figure
exit that fast would be hyper rare it
does happen
and I would rather get people thinking
about how do I build a business that's
doing a million dollars in Revenue all
the following things apply but then it's
really about reinvesting every dollar
that you're getting back into the
company to grow and scale but again it's
a problem with a killer solution that
you're doing in a unique way that didn't
require startup Capital also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is decide to be
great with Ed mylett I want to talk to
you today because I hope that of all the
talks that happen here you forget about
me but that this changes your life and I
want to remind you of something as I
begin today that you were born to do
something great with your life that
you're extraordinary listen to me that
you're enough that you're special that's
your favorite that you're chosen
regardless of where you come from
regardless of what you've been carrying
with you some of you come in here today
and you know what you've even thought of
harming yourselves
maybe you're even proud of the fact you
haven't killed yourself but every day
some of us are killing ourselves with
the shame we carry from something we've
done some humiliation some fear we put
this gun to our head every day that
tells us we're not enough we're not
strong enough pretty enough smart enough
favored enough that we're doomed and we
carry these guns in our head every day
that shame us that take our confidence
from us that steal our joy It's Like a
Knife we you don't have to kill yourself
because you do it every day
you do it over and over and over again
and there's a Better Way Forward you can
put those things down in your life you
could decide today that you were born to
do something great you could set aside
this weapon that you keep using against
yourself to hold you back from your joy
from your passion from your achievement
from all the goodies in life you could
decide today just intentionally to set
this weapon down whatever it is
something from your childhood a divorce
a business failure something you're just
not proud of that you've done set it
down stop using it as a weapon against
yourself and realize that happened for
you and not to you I'll prove it to you
I'm a big believer and fake it till you
make it
I don't want you seeing you know people
say wow social media is so full of like
these fake lives
people are always living fake lives I
was living a fake life way before social
media came along in fact when I became
an entrepreneur I wanted to be somebody
so bad I wanted to be rich so bad I
wanted to look I thought if I don't look
successful No One's Gonna listen to me
who's going to listen to a young kid in
business about how to save your money
when I didn't have any
that was my own limiting belief what's
yours
you have this kind of convoluted and
limiting belief about why you can't do
something right now that's this your own
BS story you keep telling yourself how
about you just drop that story how about
you just decide it's a lie even if it is
true
I'm not gonna just teach you not to tap
into your pain I'm gonna teach you how
to do it okay I'm not I I I teach people
how to change things technically but I
believe in this concept of living
blissfully dissatisfied which means
there's a way most people most Achievers
have it backwards they think hey if I
enjoy my success I'm going to lose all
my drive
right and then other people that aren't
successful yet haven't reached what they
want or like they delay their Bliss
until a destination in the future once I
get this relationship once I make that
money once I get that car once I have
that home then I'll let myself feel
Bliss and so I teach you that the
concept is you can live blissfully and
still be dissatisfied your pathway to
changing how you feel about yourself of
getting to the next level is always
giving always giving always giving you
know I have this thing I kind of run my
life through that kind of is my governor
on my life of what I'm trying to give
and when I'm trying to make a difference
for people and I just have this
hallucination I am a Christian and so I
believe that someday when I die there's
an accounting I don't care if you I'm
actually one of these very interesting
people that I believe in the quantum
field and energy because I know it
exists and I believe my Lord and Savior
created it that's you have whatever your
belief is is wonderful I Don't Preach I
just want you to know I know there's an
energy field I know there's a God and um
Lewis asked me on the show what are
three truths and I said the first thing
is there's a God I just want you to know
that so you believe your beliefs I
respect them I admire my people from
every belief Center in the world on my
program but I just want to say to you
this is my prism I live my life through
it governs my decision making and I make
mistakes all the time one of the cool
things about being a Christian is I'm
saved by the grace of God because I know
I'm going to sin that's one of the cool
things about my particular Faith but but
the point that I want to make because I
sin all the time I make mistakes all the
time I've already used profanity I think
four times in this talk so I know for
sure I've messed some mistakes but let
me tell you how I govern my life I
believe at the end of my life there's an
accounting and I'm going to sit in front
of my Lord and I want to say Well done
good and faithful servant but having
said that no matter what your beliefs
are
I think that I actually get to meet
somebody interesting maybe you don't
believe in anything faith-based but I
bet you believe there's a recording
going on in your life someone's paying
attention someone's going to tell the
story of your life maybe your
great-granddaughter will carry the
legacy of your life and what you've done
but someone's paying attention to what
you're doing here you've always had that
sense you've always known your life
mattered you've always known since you
were a little girl that there's
something special you're supposed to be
doing that anxiety that fear you have is
maybe you're not doing it rule number
five is craft your plan so when you
think of your goals that is the number
one thing everybody talks about so many
times in life
people think goals
will solve everything and it's a part of
it right it's a part of it we know if
you ever saw that 50-year Harvard study
you know there's only one common
denominator between a 50-year study
of the most successful people from
Harvard did you ever see that study the
only common thread of the most
successful people in Harvard no matter
what ethnic background where they came
from if they're rich or they were poor
if they got great grades or grades you
know the only common factor of the most
successful people at Harvard was
they set goals
so how important is go our goals I think
they're extremely important but I think
we have to look at goals in a different
way so I just want to give you a
different light today if you know
anything about me you know I always talk
about instead of setting a goal looking
forward
right let's pretend it is one year from
today and we're back here celebrating
and it was the best year of your life
that's the framework in which I would
love for you guys to look through
setting your goals instead of looking
forward through a busy life Look
Backwards at the best year of your life
and what had to happen when I say Look
Backwards and pretend it's the best year
of your life well your brain will
automatically go is oh yeah I want to be
making more money I want some more
freedom oh I want to lose that 10 pounds
oh I want to get the intimacy back in my
relationship that still I want to be
really I know it sounds like I'm
splitting hairs
you're still looking forward of what you
wish could happen
trained my brain over the last two
decades that when I do this exercise and
we have to do it right here when you do
this exercise it's not about looking
what you hope to happen
it's about saying it already happened
and how do you feel looking backwards
meaning put yourself in that spot and if
it's visualization if it's a little
quiet time if it's reflecting if it's
why you take a walk if it's in your
shower when you're meditating whatever
it is picture it like I literally I
literally can spend time thinking about
where I'm going to be in a year from now
and I can literally get goosebumps and I
can feel it as if it exists right now
you know people talk about manifesting
and all it is manifesting you got to do
the work it's not about just dreaming
and hope it happens I'm not a believer
in that a lot of people say you set the
intention the universe will deliver
you have to set it up and you
actually have to do the work you can't
just say ah I'd like to have a million
dollars in my bank account let me go
back to my old habits of surfing on the
internet and watching Netflix and hope
that million dollars shows up no we
gotta we gotta do the work so we'll get
a little deeper but the first thing is
is we must have that compelling future
of our own design and for me I literally
can put myself in this place
and I remember writing down okay this is
what Mastermind has to look like and I
remember writing down 100 miles and oh
we're going to do a big launch and we're
going to call it the knowledge business
blueprint and I remember writing it down
and I was writing down as if it already
happened I literally if you could see
the hair on my arms it's standing up
right here because I can visualize
because I've been practicing this for so
long that I visualize it and I see it
that is a great practice then once we
see it then the part that I think has to
happen as soon as I was done visualizing
I didn't go done I dreamed it up no then
I got my ass to work like who do I need
to learn from to do this who do I have
to model what patterns of successful
people who've already done this that I
could model and do in teaching this and
then I started making the list of what I
had to get done so that fantasy could
become a reality this might sound like
this is what everybody does but do we we
all agreed if we eat better and work out
more we'd be in better shape but most of
us want to be in better shape but we
don't eat better and we don't work out
more so a lot of us want to be next
level successful and we're looking for
something else magically to come along
and it's not gonna we have to visualize
what it is we want to be and if it was
the best year of Our Lives we have to
get as detailed as possible remember
fuzzy targets don't get hit
don't just say I want to be a coach
making a million dollars a year
what does that mean what kind of Coach
how many coaching sessions how many
clients do you need listen if you said I
want to be a coach and I want to make a
million dollars a year and you're
sitting with me
and I was Consulting for you I'd reverse
engineer it how many people how much do
you make per person right if you say I
can make you know it's ten thousand
dollars a year per person okay so that
means you need 100 clients okay you need
100 clients over 12 months it's going to
take you first month you might only get
five so if you get five the first month
and then the second month is seven then
the third month is is 20. how many do
you need to get I would lay out all
right first month five second month 12
third month I need 22 and I'd have a
freaking goal every month on how I could
get there and nothing would stop me I
would go back to what I teach you guys
I'd know my why I'd have my compelling
future I already visualized it I knew
how I feel once I made a million dollars
being a coach I know how I would
visualize how the people I'm coaching's
lives would change I would think about
if I'm saving marriages or helping
people eat better or learn how to sell
or learn how to go vegan or or a million
other things I would think about the
lives I'm changing and I would literally
craft the plan saying okay a million
dollars
as a coach okay I need a hundred clients
that's an average of 10-ish eightish a
month right whatever that is
I might not get as many the first ones
so I got to stack up the other months
and then I'd say okay what is my plan to
get the first five in January and I
would craft the plan to get my five ten
thousand dollar coaching sessions in
January and that would be my whole
Obsession and if I got four well I got
to get an extra one in February if I got
six I'm like I'm ahead of the game Let's
bust it in February and let's keep this
little cushion that I have
right I just want to tell you I'm not
trying to say the way I do is perfect
but I meet so many people that set goals
and then dabble and hope it's like even
if you have the recipe you gotta cook
the meal there's no one coming over to
do it animal number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
Master one thing with Tony Robbins I'm
20 years old I'm in college right now
I'm in my junior year the hours are
really crazy because I'm going to school
for game design that's what I really
want to do but I really want to I really
want to be able to just purchase my own
game Studio okay
um so I also um I work part-time I have
um I just started a marketing business
just to try and bring more money in but
this is the first business thing I've
ever done and I'm trying to um start my
own gaming YouTube channel just to get
my name more out there and learn how to
put my learn basically how to get on my
own following and become an influencer
for video games myself okay my question
is is how how do you know whether or not
you're trying to basically take too much
on right are you stretching yourself in
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like I want to
know I got it how do you know when you
get to that point I got it Tony this is
such a classic question for a lot of
entrepreneurs you've done it I've done
it we've lived our lives right like you
know like what where does where does
doing a lot of different things to see
if there's upside in it which all my
great things have come from
um stop and where does it start to
you're taking on too much and now you're
trying to do everything which means
you're doing nothing yeah
thank you for the question
must start a business very often we'll
start two and three four more and the
reason they do it is because the first
one isn't succeeding or they no longer
patients exactly right and so what
happens that person is they're never
going to be successful in most cases
unless they get lucky you get lucky you
can bounce across something that's
easier to do but most people are always
looking for that next level what my view
is is it's great to test all these
things but you got to find what is your
Flagship what is it that you're gonna
commit your soul to because if you don't
do that the inevitable challenges are
going to come up and you're going to
then move on to something 100 enjoyable
and so the other thing I look at is
business
constantly not only adding such massive
value doing more for others than anybody
else but it's also simultaneously about
your own psychology it's your ability to
go through thresholds of control
um it's like I can remember when I
didn't have fifty thousand dollars to
keep the doors open on my company I had
12 employees and 11 wanted to quit
because they hated the person running
the show and fifty thousand dollars
would be like 500 million to me today
and I figured out how to get through
that threshold and once I did like all
the problems related that were handled I
know you've done this as well and then I
you know I had a five million dollar
lawsuit was totally unfair unjust and I
finally had just the amount of time
energy running out of bite the bullet
dude and five million was more than I
ever met then I have a partner who took
a company losing a million dollars a day
and turned into 1.5 billion in positive
ebitda I'm not mentioning names Amway
and he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners not doing the
multi-level side did the business put in
10 million bucks we all put in 10
million 40 million at that but I signed
joint and several which I didn't
understand in those days without man and
two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke we
bought some more companies I ended up
with 120 million dollars in debt that I
was on the hook for no one else had any
money and I'm good enough to do a
seminar wanting to throw up it was a new
threshold of control so you know when
you ski or you snowboard and you think
you're maybe you're just new at it and
you think you're going down a blue or
green it turns out to be a double block
and you're like yeah and so you have two
choices one is you start to go down and
you freak out you're gonna die you slam
on the ground try to hang on for dear
life or the other is baby you focus on
where you want to go find a way to curve
you find a way to
once you do it a couple of times you get
used to it you have no more fear of that
element now my biggest one out of that
that led me to a billion I have 31
companies now to give you an idea seven
different Industries as diverse as like
uh you know stem cells to virtual
reality you have the exclusive to the
NDA now virtually how to get an example
we do I got 1200 employees we're on
three continents and we got five billion
dollars in sales but I did that because
I first stayed on one freaking thing
exactly so masterful at it that I I the
way I look kind of give it one more
metaphor probably not old enough to
remember this but I'm old member a guy
I'm pretty old melwood's name he was the
guy that Mel's Diner the great 80s
no the guy that looked for gold on the
Spanish Galleon I forget his name now
let me know this but anyway he found a
half a billion dollars in gold but it
took him like 31 years to do it and you
can't live on that maybe maybe he loved
the journey though he did not love the
joke okay his son was killed on the
journey well that's bad he made no if
you can imagine 30 one years of going
out there getting money from investors
and showing nothing I mean after a year
two five ten at some point your breaking
point he never does Breaking points so I
looked at my businesses back then and I
was always looking for the new business
that was a great opportunity I loved
what I was doing it's emotionally
rewarding but low margin business and I
had these meetings with a group of
billionaires and they said you have not
maximized and then I saw this guy now
and I thought I don't believe I have not
the right beliefs you need three beliefs
to be successful in your business the
highest level you have to believe number
one what did this guy have to believe to
go 31 years he had to believe number one
that the treasure was out there number
two he had to believe I'm gonna find it
and number three I believe is gonna be
worth it yeah if you don't believe
there's that treasure in your business
you're finished you've got to use those
three things to go to another level
yeah
you need that instinct for meaning too
so and we should get this real straight
why do you need it well you need it
because life is really really difficult
right I mean people have a rough time of
it there's plenty of suffering in life
and everyone is going to encounter it
right there you don't you know you learn
this as a clinical psychologist and you
know this generally you know unless
you're an extraordinarily fortunate
person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lives they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see see the skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and they turn and
they turn in a very bad Direction and
then they make everything that's already
bad way worse and we're very very
inventive at such things and so that's
not good unless that's the path you want
that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning I never
graduated from college
and this is the closest I've ever gotten
to a college graduation
[Music]
today I want to tell you three stories
from my life that's it no big deal just
three stories
the first story
is about connecting the dots
I dropped out of Reed College after the
first six months but then stayed around
as a drop-in for another 18 months or so
before I really quit
so why'd I drop out
[Music]
it started before I was born
my biological mother was a young unwed
graduate student and she decided to put
me up for adoption
she felt very strongly that I should be
adopted by college graduates so
everything was all set for me to be
adopted at Birth by a lawyer and his
wife
except that when I popped out they
decided at the last minute that they
really wanted a girl
so my parents who were on a waiting list
got a call in the middle of the night
asking
we've got an unexpected baby boy if you
want him
they said of course
my biological mother found out later
that my mother had never graduated from
college and that my father had never
graduated from high school
she refused to sign the final adoption
papers
she only relented a few months later
when my parents promised that I would go
to college
this was the start in my life
[Music]
and 17 years later I did go to college
but I naively chose a college that was
almost as expensive as Stanford
and all of my working-class parent
savings were being spent on my college
tuition
after six months I couldn't see the
value in it I had no idea what I wanted
to do with my life and no idea how
College was going to help me figure it
out
and here I was spending all the money my
parents had saved their entire life
so I decided to drop out and trust that
it would all work out okay
it was pretty scary at the time but
looking back it was one of the best
decisions I ever made
the minute I dropped out I could stop
taking the required classes that didn't
interest me and begin dropping in on the
ones that looked far more interesting
it wasn't all romantic I didn't have a
dorm room so I slept on the floor in
friends rooms
I returned Coke bottles for the five
cent deposits to buy food with
and I would walk the seven miles across
town every Sunday night
to get one good meal a week at the Hari
Krishna Temple
I loved it
and much of what I stumbled into by
following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be Priceless later on
let me give you one example
read college at that time offered
perhaps the best calligraphy instruction
in the country
throughout the campus every poster every
label on every drawer was beautifully
hand calligraphed
because I had dropped out and didn't
have to take the normal classes
I decided to take a calligraphy class to
learn how to do this
I learned about serif and sans-serif
typefaces about varying the amount of
space between different letter
combinations about what makes great
typography great
it was beautiful historical artistically
subtle in a way that science can't
capture
and I found it fascinating
none of this had even a hope of any
practical application in my life
but ten years later when we were
designing the first Macintosh computer
it all came back to me and we designed
it all into the Mac it was the first
computer with beautiful typography
if I had never dropped in on that single
course in college the Mac would have
never had multiple typefaces or
proportionally spaced fonts and since
Windows just copied the Mac it's likely
that no personal computer would have
them
[Applause]
[Music]
if I had never dropped out I would have
never dropped in on that calligraphy
class and personal computers might not
have the wonderful typography that they
do
of course it was impossible to connect
the dots looking forward when I was in
college but it was very very clear
looking backwards 10 years later
again you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards
so you have to trust that the dots will
somehow connect in your future you have
to trust in something your gut Destiny
Life Karma whatever
because believing that the dots will
connect down the road
will give you the confidence to follow
your heart even when it leads you off
the well-worn path and that will make
all the difference my second story is
about love and loss
I was lucky I found what I love to do
early in life was and I started Apple in
my parents garage when I was 20. we
worked hard and in 10 years Apple had
grown from Just the Two of Us in a
garage into a two billion dollar company
with over four thousand employees we
just released our finest creation the
Macintosh a year earlier and I just
turned 30.
and then I got fired
how can you get fired from a company you
started
well as Apple grew we hired someone who
I thought was very talented to run the
company with me and for the first year
or so things went well but then our
visions of the future began to diverge
and eventually we had a falling out
when we did our board of directors sided
with him and so at 30 I was out and very
publicly out
what had been the focus of my entire
adult life was gone and it was
devastating
I really didn't know what to do for a
few months
I felt that I'd let the previous
generation of entrepreneurs down that I
had dropped the Baton as it was being
passed to me
I met with David Packard and Bob Noyes
and tried to apologize for screwing up
so badly
I was a very public failure and I even
thought about running away from the
valley
but something slowly began to dawn on me
I still loved what I did
the turn of events at Apple had not
changed that one bit
I'd been rejected but I was still in
love
and so I decided to start over
I didn't see it then but it turned out
that getting fired from Apple was the
best thing that could have ever happened
to me
the heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner again less sure about
everything
it freed me to enter one of the most
creative periods of my life
during the next five years I started a
company named next another company named
Pixar and fell in love with an amazing
woman who would become my wife
Pixar went on to create the world's
first computer animated feature film Toy
Story and is now the most successful
Animation Studio in the world
in a remarkable turn of events
Apple bought next and I returned to
Apple and the technology we developed it
next is at the heart of Apple's current
Renaissance
and Laureen and I have a wonderful
family together
I'm pretty sure none of this would have
happened if I hadn't been fired from
Apple
it was awful tasting medicine but I
guess the patient needed it
sometime life sometimes life's going to
hit you in the head with a brick
don't lose faith
I'm convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that I loved what I
did you've got to find what you love and
that is as true for work as it is for
your lovers
your work is going to fill a large part
of your life and the only way to be
truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great work and the only way
to do great work is to love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't settle
as with all matters of the heart you'll
know when you find it and like any great
relationship it just gets better and
better as the years roll on so keep
looking don't settle
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
my third story
is about death
when I was 17 I read a quote that when
something like if you live each day as
if it was your last someday you'll most
certainly be right
it made an impression on me and since
then for the past 33 years I've looked
in the mirror every morning and asked
myself if today were the last day of my
life what I want to do what I am about
to do today
and whenever the answer has been no for
too many days in a row I know I need to
change something
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life
because almost everything all external
expectations all Pride all fear of
embarrassment or failure these things
just fall away in the face of death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the Trap of
thinking you have something to lose you
are already naked there is no reason not
to follow your heart
about a year ago I was diagnosed with
cancer
I had a scan at 7 30 in the morning and
it clearly showed a tumor on my pancreas
I didn't even know what a pancreas was
the doctors told me this was almost
certainly a type of cancer that is
incurable and that I should expect to
live no longer than three to six months
doctor advised me to go home and get my
Affairs in order which is doctor's code
for prepare to die
it means to try and tell your kids
everything
you thought you'd have the next 10 years
to tell them in just a few months
it means to make sure everything is
buttoned up so that it will be as easy
as possible for your family
it means to say your goodbyes
I live with that diagnosis all day later
that evening I had a biopsy where they
stuck an endoscope down my throat
through my stomach and into my
intestines put a needle into my pancreas
and got a few cells from the tumor
I was sedated but my wife who was there
told me that when they viewed the cells
under a microscope the doctor started
crying because it turned out to be a
very rare form of pancreatic cancer that
is curable with surgery I had the
surgery and thankfully I'm fine now
foreign
this was the closest I've been to facing
death and I hope it's the closest I get
for a few more decades having lived
through it I can now say this to you
with a bit more certainty than when
death was a useful but purely
intellectual concept
no one wants to die
even people who want to go to heaven
don't want to die to get there
and yet
f is the destination we all share no one
has ever escaped it and that is as it
should be because death is very likely
the single best invention of life
it's life's change agent it clears out
the old to make way for the new
right now the new is you
but someday not too long from now you
will gradually become the old and be
cleared away
sorry to be so dramatic but it's quite
true
your time is limited so don't waste it
living someone else's life
don't be trapped by Dogma which is
living with the results of other
people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become everything else is secondary
[Music]
when I was young there was an amazing
publication called the whole earth
catalog which was one of the Bibles of
my generation
it was created by a fellow named Stuart
brand not far from here in Menlo Park
and he brought it to life with his
poetic touch
this was in the late 60s before personal
computers and desktop publishing so it
was all made with typewriters scissors
and Polaroid cameras it was sort of like
Google and paperback form 35 years
before Google came along
it was idealistic overflowing with neat
tools and great Notions
Stewart and his team put out several
issues of the whole earth catalog and
then when it had run its course they put
out a final issue it was the mid-1970s
and I was your age
on the back cover of their final issue
was a photograph of an early morning
Country Road the kind you might find
yourself hitchhiking on if you were so
adventurous
beneath it were the words stay hungry
stay foolish
it was their farewell message as they
signed off
stay hungry stay foolish
and I have always wished that for myself
and now as you graduate to begin anew
I wish that for you
stay hungry stay foolish
thank you all very much there's no
question that that that
capitalism
as it gets more advanced will widen the
gap between the people that have Market
skills whatever that market demands
and uh and others unless government does
something in between which say the
earned income tax credit or all kinds of
things and and I think that's a proper
function so I would I would I would say
that if people
it isn't some diabolical plot or
anything but look at it this way if you
go back to eighteen hundred and eighty
percent of the people were farmers and
you were the best farmer in Omaha and I
was the worst the difference in our
value might be two to one you might be
worthwise as much if we aren't there
picking horn or whatever we might be
doing or planning but
now
there's we'll say two million times
there's 30 million
American males between 20 and 35.
and if you're in the top one tenth of
one percent in basketball ability or
football ability or baseball you aren't
worth anything
if you're in the top hundredth of one
percent you're getting close so
if that's if the payoff is huge because
some guy discovered television many
years ago and another guy discovered pay
TV or cable and then pay TV so that your
talents
where Ted Williams got twenty thousand
dollars a year for batting 406. your
talents now if you if you make the
majors still doesn't pay well on the
miners but if you finally get to that
100th of one percent now you're you're
worth millions and uh one tenth of one
percent you can I don't think you can
just play Sam Hunt ball and so you get
this pushing of extreme rewards to
people who are very very good at
something the market demands and people
demand entertainment they demand people
apparently that Arbitrage Securities
here I mean there's all there's certain
Specialties and uh
that isn't because a bunch of people are
sitting in a room deciding we're going
to figure out how to take it away from
the poor or anything like that it's
because of the market system but we want
the market system to keep functioning
that way but we don't want people left
behind in a society where you've got
sixty thousand dollars plus of GDP per
capita it
and that
the people on the on in the lower half
have been getting falling behind the
games overall achieved by the country
and we've
they aren't worse off than they were 20
years ago they're somewhat better off
and they're better off they're better
off because of things like an iPhone I
mean you know that's that's something
that's terribly useful and and everybody
I get the benefits of search you know
for nothing you know basically and but
that's the ultimate tension is how do
you keep a system that produces and
incredible benefits for everybody you
know Sports is an easy example because
we all like to to watch them we don't
want to watch a bunch of guys like you
and me
so that's where the money is but that
didn't exist 200. how do we address that
we address it through things like the
Earned Income Tax Credit we address it
so that anybody that worked 40 hours a
week
and as a couple of kids that they don't
need a second job in the family they can
have a decent life does that mean
increasing the minimum wage it means
increasingly earned income tax credit
because I think that's a better system
yeah what they need is more money in
their pockets yeah now you can do more
money in the pocket through minimum wage
but you don't have work have as many
people working yeah you need something
so they have money in their pocket right
and we can do that and that does require
a in my view it requires higher taxes on
people that
where they were born into this world
with peculiar talents that that
marvelously now and and 200 years ago
they would have been out there picking
corn with me can you take the higher
taxes on wealthy people and put it
directly to the Earned Income Tax Credit
well you could I mean because people
complain oh my taxes are going well they
squandered yeah nobody likes taxes out
yeah but if you put had a program where
it was earmarked well that's that's what
people do in their
whether on the debate stage you know
currently it's the Democrats and they
they tell you all their new programs and
how they'll pay for it but they don't
tell you how to pay for the ones are
already there nobody's discussed the
trillion dollar deficit we have so to
talk about how you're going to introduce
some new but based
base you don't want to run deficits
indefinitely that increase the
relationship that the GB there's there's
some point at which that causes real
problems although we haven't seen it a
lot of places that you might expect to
see it but
this country has
the the productive capacity
to let people like me live
extraordinarily well or sports stars or
entertainment stars all kinds of good
managers whatever
and still make sure that nobody is
really
left so that two people have to work and
you have to hold two jobs and you wonder
how you're going to feed your kids if
you're if you're working you know 750 an
hour doesn't do it and ten dollars an
hour doesn't do it but we can do it we
have the resources to do it when I
analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back over there on my on
my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
uh you need to learn how to manage you
need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats that you have to
wear
uh or you have to make sure that
somebody in your company is wearing that
hat right and so imagine if you're um
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do you'd have to
find how do I get somebody who could do
the surgery so for those of you who are
not good at marketing or sales which is
the oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done I'm going to teach
you the entrepreneur success formula
this is the formula it's very simple
it's easy to apply that when you
actually execute it it will change the
course of your life and your business
the entrepreneur success formula are you
ready you need to if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur combine what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people
people messes up what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
in that intersection is your next great
genius amazing business idea here's what
most people do
most people just pick one
most people either pick what they love
doing
but they can't figure out how to bring
value to other people so you've got a
hobby if you love doing something it
just fills you up it's amazing but it
never brings value to other people then
you never get paid you've got a really
fulfilling Hobby and that could be great
and your hobby can be something you do
in the evenings and weekends and it
fills up your soul but you'll never turn
that into a business if you don't figure
out how to bring value to other people
so you're stuck always having to have a
job or go work for somebody else while
you're doing your hobby on the on the
weekends evenings on the side Etc so
those are the people who just Chase what
they love doing right they chase Your
Passion amazing
there's other people a lot of
entrepreneurs who just go after the
money
just try to bring value just go after
opportunity right that's the only focus
like I'll do whatever it takes I need to
be a millionaire by the time I'm X years
old I'll do whatever it takes but you
won't you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
gonna lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a magazine
or website it shows you the hottest
businesses for next year these are the
industries that we'll take off and you
have to get into it it's like oh wow
that's hot I'm gonna go off and do those
things if you don't absolutely love it
right this part here if you don't
actually love it what you love doing
what it brings value to other people if
you don't absolutely love it
You're Gonna Lose because you're going
up against people who do love it if it's
just a strategy for you but for other
people they love it you're gonna lose
every time you can lose every time
because while you're counting the hours
and while you're trying to figure out oh
my gosh when is this going to pay off
you're going up against people who
aren't even tracking it who get lost in
it who 12 hours later they're still
doing a thing because they love it so
much and they can't believe that where
is a time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because they're thinking to make a lot
of money and they end up going broke and
it wasn't because the idea was bad the
idea could have been fantastic the
problem was you didn't love it enough
you didn't care about it enough it was
just a strategy it was just an
opportunity for you instead of being
actually something that you love so the
entrepreneur's success formula
you start with doing what you love
and then you figure out how to bring
value to other people doing it another
way I like to explain it is your heart
and your head so you make the big
decisions in life with your heart on the
small ones with your head what you work
on what you do what you're what you're
spending your time on day in day it has
to be heart driven it's got to be
something that fills you up with so much
joy but then your head needs to be part
of the equation too to say okay okay
heart that's great that you love doing
is saying but how are we going to make
money how we're going to bring value to
other people so you make the big
decisions with your heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to make
it actually practical so you're not just
daydreaming constantly in la la land
we're actually turning it into something
that can have a massive impact on the
world
the entrepreneur success formula you
gotta do what you love
and figure out a way to bring value to
other people doing it when I started
making my YouTube channel
I never thought I was going to make
money I did it because I love doing I
did it because I wanted visual content
I'm a visual learner I struggled in
reading books it took me a long time
when I read a book unless it's really
short chapters and and really spaced out
well I would find myself reading five
pages of the book and then realizing I
read five pages and I have no idea what
I just read so I had to go back and read
those five pages again I would look how
long a chapter was and see oh my gosh
it's 40 pages this chapter is going to
kill me I read because I I needed to
because I wanted knowledge but it was a
really inefficient way for me to learn
I'm a visual learner I like to see
things and so said well why hasn't
somebody made this
and I wanted to be around successful
famous entrepreneurs because I didn't
have anybody in my life who had achieved
what I wanted to achieve and so that was
the root of why I started making my my
videos and my content and before YouTube
on my website which was similar idea of
sharing the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and what you can learn
from their success
so I did it for myself
and then figured out how can I do this
so that I can make money doing it so
that I can do this as my full-time thing
so that I can recruit a team of people
to help me do this so now we've got a
team of people who are all building
these channels with me so I can create
even more impact and make even more
videos
the combination LED first with what I
love doing I want to create content that
speaks to 19 year old Evan who was
struggling who doesn't know what to do
who who's making 300 bucks a month was
broke who wanted to do something big but
had very little belief in himself and
and didn't have a plan for what to do
next I still make my videos for 19 year
old Evan
and I had to figure out a way to turn it
into a profitable business so that I can
have a bigger reach and be able to do
this full-time plus and have a team to
help me do it
entrepreneur success formula what you
love doing with what brings value to
other people okay so how do we do it how
do we start to figure out that process
that's an easy formula but underneath it
let's let's dive a little deeper to give
you even more value step number one is
embrace the end most people are thinking
or most people are thinking do I do this
or doing this do I do this business or
do this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your heart
centered thing that you could do all day
you probably have a couple things and
you feel like you have to pick this is
the mistake people feel like you have to
pick you don't have to pick the actual
selection is in doing both of those
things combined a lot of people have
said some amazing things of me is very
humbling I think of Ed mylett and
garyvee where garyvee called me the DJ
that likes to watch so much content and
then spin it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said that I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill is the
biggest influence of all time personal
development and I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how I'm
unique because I love consuming all of
this stuff and I love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how I'm
Different there's a lot of people who
are just sharing their message and
there's a lot of people who are also
mixing things together but there's
nobody who's really mixing things
together and sharing their own message
right so instead of looking at those two
things as different Brian's like I have
to pick I got to pick this or this like
I'm going to combine them and that's how
I'm going to be unique so think about
your different interests what do you
love doing what are what are your top
two three things that you can get lost
in and they feel completely different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
using that to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end step number two is try to get as
close to customers as possible so it's
great to be making it's big it's great
to be creative it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos I need the videos for
myself and then I share them and it
helps other people right so I solved the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first I know there's
lots of people like you but you need to
start talking to customers you need to
start getting their feedback you need to
start seeing what they interact with and
that can help guide a lot of your future
product or service creation you need to
get out of just sitting by yourself on
your couch researching and into actually
talking to people so a quick example
from my channel
the whole top 10 rules of success thing
came because I just made one video on
Kanye West that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do Dame Dash hey can you do
Jay-Z hey can you do Jeff Bezos hey can
you do Steve Jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea sure
why not I could do that I never thought
of it as being a whole series I just was
wanted to give a tribute to Kanye West
and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person I still
get final say we ended up having over 2
000 different requests for people to
profile I still get final say as to who
we profile
because I have to feel connected to the
message and when I'm pulling out the
content if we're doing Kanye West or
Steve Jobs is always something positive
it's always through the lens of belief
because that's what I want to put out I
don't want to put out Kanye West's
biggest attacks or insults or negativity
I want to put out negativity in the
world I could easily done top 10 top 10
Kanye West stupidest things you've ever
done I'm not interested in putting that
out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what I
love doing right what I want to put my
stake in the ground to say I made this
right this is the contribution that I'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur success formula right what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people so how to figure out what
brings value out of the people you have
to get as close to the customer as
possible understand their business
understand what they're going through
understand their mindset you solving the
problem for yourself is a good first
step and then going into okay what are
you struggling with so number one is
embrace the end number two is get as
close as possible to the customer and
then number three is solve a problem
solve a problem
as you're talking to customers
as you're talking to people who will be
using your product or your service who
will be engaging with your content as
you're talking to these people what is
the problem that they're facing
what is the struggle what is the
challenge that they're facing and then
help them accomplish it
if I apply it to myself and the YouTube
channels for context
one of the biggest challenges I think
people have is a very poor environment
you've got people in your life who keep
you where you are some people may be
telling you that you can't do things
that's the worst case scenario some
people might be cheering you on but they
can't guide you you're not inspired by
them the people around you are not
inspiring enough for you and that's why
you're stuck because the environment is
keeping you small
where if you're around higher Achievers
if you're around Tomball you and Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and these people
they would pull you to be better and so
that's the biggest problem that I see
the entrepreneurs that I love helping is
you know you're capable of more you've
got this big mission inside you you've
got the heart and the care and the
willingness to serve you've got
everything but you're not being pulled
forward by anybody
and so I want to try to create that
through content because you may not be
able to hang out with Tom bilio and Elon
musking up or Winfrey but every day on
YouTube you can hang out with Tom Billy
Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey from the
content that I'm going to make and
create right so that's the problem that
I'm trying to solve
and I get that because it was me who
struggled with it but also the people
that I see who I connect with who are
watching the videos they're leaving
feedback from me and I'm talking to them
and I realize you've got everything
you've got everything you you've got
everything
you're just missing that environment to
push you forward so that's the problem
that I solve what is the problem that
you solve when you can combine your
passions right step number one you're
combine in your passions
step number two is we're talking to
customers people who are going to use
potentially what we can create and then
you're understanding what their problem
is and you solve it for them
that's how we start to build a
successful business
back to the entrepreneur success formula
if you get this formula if you apply it
it's simple it's basic and it's one of
the most powerful things you can ever do
and it's the one of the biggest reasons
why entrepreneurs don't win
despite having the heart and the care
and the service you have to combine the
thing that you love doing with all your
heart with something that brings value
to other people
bring those things together and you're
on to your next successful business
career
[Music]
as you made it this far in a video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to take action on your
dreams check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I still
don't believe in myself to do the next
thing I'm the believe guy well I believe
in myself to do this but to do the next
thing that's the struggle so it's a
constant how do I believe in myself to
do the next big thing well how do I then
teach beliefs